we've had a wonderful time here today
and that brings us to our last track
thank you Great Escape thank you Brian
thank you jams once more for putting us
on let's end this on a little bit of a
of a sticky note hey yeah
we go yeah non-stop trouble when she
busts up who I know the girl then turn
their head at the same damn time
[Music]
stop trouble when she step one let's see
make the player actually out there
pouring us
[Music]
to the right
Angel but the temple in our eyes don't
stop fall out her lips softness passion
from the way that she kissed must be in
the present cause you're truly a gift
wrapped in plastic no I cannot resist
you
at three o'clock on a Friday tight up
skirts
[Music]
now I hope you understand me
at 3 P.M you lot really
[Music]
all right here we go
understand me
[Music]
see The Vibes is up here
but Brighton what goes up must come down
[Music]
when I see my reflection I see signs of
your reflection man tell me one more
time
yes yes
[Music]
tell me one more time
top skirts
or Sweet Sticky like candy language now
I hope you understand me
[Music]
twinkle little
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
tight up skirt drink a little Brandy
yellow So Sweet Sticky Sticky like candy
language now I hope you understand me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a whole lot of fun writing have
an incredible rest of your day
well speechless
we got Grove big up EJ did you not enjoy
that sorry I'm shouting so excited that
was a lot wow I've never seen a crowd
like that at the Great Escape festival
and I think it means so much to look out
and actually have people dancing and
enjoying it not just like head nodding
so make some noise for yourself as well